Every great why needs
a great how.
>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT, FIRST
UP.
ROBERT DE NIRO IS TRULY ONE OF
HOLLYWOOD'S ICONIC TOUGH GUYS
BUT HIS ACT ISN'T SO
AWARD-WINNING WHEN HE TALKS
>> THIS [BLEEP] IDIOT IS THE
PRESIDENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
IT'S THE EMPEROR'S NEW CLOTHES.
THE GUY IS A [BLEEP] FOOL, COME
ON.
OUR BABY IN CHIEF, [BLEEP] IN
CHIEF, I CALL HIM.
>> Laura: I THINK HE MEANS THE
EMPEROR HAS NO CLOTHES, IF
SOMEONE DOESN'T WRITE HIS LINES
HE BLOWS THEM.
HE'S BEEN MOUTHING OFF FOR YEARS
HE'S BEEN MOUTHING OFF FOR YEAR
YEARS.
I HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE A PLANE
RIDE WITH HIM ONCE.
DRINKING JACK DANIEL'S AT 1:00
IN THE AFTERNOON.
HE IS OFF THE RAILS GOOD >> I
ENGAGES IN THIS KIND OF AD
GENUINELY LOVE HIS WORK, HE'S A
GREAT ACTOR.
DON'T DO THIS, IT EMBARRASSES
YOU, WITHOUT THE LINE IT'S
TROUBLE.
THEY SAY SOME ACTORS TAKE THE
ROLE HOME WITH HIM.
HE'S CAUGHT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
>> Laura: TALK ABOUT ICONIC,
FRENCH ACTRESS AMAZING.
SHE IS AS BEAUTIFUL AS EVER.
SHE HAD A FEW THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THE #MeToPost --Movement.
>>THISISTHEBACKLASHTOTHEMOVEMENT
MEN HAVE BEEN PUNISHED
SUMMARILY WHEN ALL THEY DID IS
TOUCH SOMEONE'S KNEE OR TRY TO
STEAL A KISS.
AS WOMEN WE DO NOT RECOGNIZE
THE ABUSE OF POWER AND TAKES ON
A HATRED OF MEN AND SEXUALITY.
>> Laura: SOMEONE'S KNEE OR
TRY TO STEAL A KISS.
>> THEY TAKE THIS IN TOTALITY,
THEY ARE SAYING WAIT WE MAY HAVE
GONE TOO FAR.
SOME MEN HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATELY DRIVEN FROM
THEIR JOBS ON JUST IN ACCUSATION
THEIR JOBS ON JUST IN ACCUSATIO
ACCUSATION.
>> Laura: SO MUCH FOR EVER
DATING SOMEONE YOU WORK WITH, I
GUESS THAT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE MARRIED
AND HAVE SIX AND SEVEN KIDS WHO
MARRIED THEIR HUSBAND AT WORK,
TODAY WITH YOUNG PEOPLE, YOU
CAN'T EVER DATE ANYBODY.
>> THESE WOMEN DO GO OUT OF
THEIR WAY, THESE ARE WELL-KNOWN
WOMEN.
>> Laura: THE DEMONIZATION OF
MEN.
ABUSE IS ABUSE IS ABUSE.
>> LET'S NOT GET CARRIED AWAY.
>> Laura: THE BEST EVER WAS
MERYL STREEP LAST WEEK SAYING
THAT DUSTIN HOFFMAN IN 1979,
ANOTHER FILM I LOVED IT WAS
SEARING THAT FILM.
THAT SCENE WHERE HE SLAPS HER,
HE SLAPPED ME TOO HARD.
IS THAT A METHOD ACTING?
SHE   HE SLEPT TOO HARD?
>> MAYBE SHE DESERVED IT.
>> Laura: ALLIE SHEEDY THE
ACTRESS FROM THOSE OLD 80s
FILMS, SHE NEVER DID DO THE
DINNER CLUB, SHE CALLED OUT
ACTOR JAMES FRANCO AFTER HE WAS
AT THE GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS.
SHE SAID THAT JAMES FRANCO JUST
ONE, PLEASE NEVER ASK ME WHY I
LEFT THE TV AND FILM BUSINESS.
>> SHE CLAIMS THAT THERE WAS
SOME CHICANERY GOING ON.
ONE ACTRESS ON TWITTER AFTER HE
WON THE GOLDEN GLOBE
HE MADE HER TAKE HER CLOTHES OFF
FOR A FILM, ANOTHER CLAIMS HE
>> Laura: WE HAVE A FILM OUT
OF AN ADULT MAN SEDUCING A
17-YEAR-OLD BOY AND THAT'S
CALLED "CALL ME BY YOUR NAME" I
CAN'T REMEMBER IT AT ALL.
THAT IS THE EPIC ART-HOUSE FILM
OF THE YEAR.
ADULT MAN SEDUCING AN UNDERAGE
BOY THAT JAMES FRANCO APPARENTLY
CAN'T SEDUCE A 17 --
I NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
CONFUSING RULES.
>> HE GOT UP AND ACCEPTED IT
WITH A TIMES OF A BUTTON ON HIS
LAPEL.
HOLLYWOOD UNDERMINED HIMSELF AND
ITS MESSAGE BY GIVING THIS GUY A
GOLDEN GLOBE WHEN HE MAY BE ONE
OF THE MALEFACTORS HERE, ONE OF
THE GUYS THEY MAY NEED TO STRIKE
FROM THE RECORD.
"NEW YORK TIMES" TODAY CANCELED
AN EVENT WITH HIM.
>> Laura: SHOULD WE PLAY HIM
ON COLBERT?
>> HE SAID I'M NOT SURE.